[Musique]
et Michel c'est lié au sujet du grand
froid le plan grand froid justement est
déclenchant en Île-de-France comment ça
va se traduire dans les evvelines et
bien grégoryi on a appris en fin de
journée l'activation du plan grand froid
dans les evvine par la préfecture par
plan grand froid comprenait un épisode
de temps froid caractérisé par sa
persistance son intensité et son étendue
géographique selon la définition de
météorance on écoute le préfet desiv
Jean-Jacques bR au micro de Julien Leroi
le préfet de la région î-de-france a
déclenché pour Paris le plan grand froid
hier ce matin il y avait coordination de
tous les départements le plan grand
froid consistera dès qu'il sera mis en
œuvre dans quelques minutes dans le
département des ivelines à avoir une
préoccupation particulière pour les
personnes sans abri une augmentation de
plusieurs dizaines de places centaines
sans doute d'hébergement d'urgence
intensification des marodes et puis
réactivité en lien naturellement avec
les services hospitaliers les
municipalités qui sont au première loge
avec le Conseil départemental Dans ce et
les associations bien entendu dans ce
travail de mise à l'abri autre actualité
à retenir ce lundi le service des
urgences de l'hôpital de meland les
Mureau a engagé une grève illimitée en
tout cas quelques-uns des des agents sur
place oui c'est pas un communiqué de la
CGT qui a été annoncée une grève
illimitée à des urgences du centre
hospitalier intercommunal parmi les
revendications les équipes demandent la
création d'un poste d'infirmière
supplémentaire la nuit afin de sécuriser
les soins la direction aurait refusé se
justifiant d'un taux de passage annuel
qu'elle juge insuffisant selon le
communiqué de la CGT cette grève
illimitée s'inscrit dans un contexte
général de tension au sein des Urgences
toujours selon le syndicat de
l'établissement de nombreux agents ont
déjà fui le centre hospitalier en raison
de conditions de travail dégradé un
rassemblement a été organisé à 14h
aujourd'hui devant l'établissement une
information qui ne devrait pas
satisfaire les usagers de la ligne ha
oui face aux nombreux dysfonctionnement
que subissent au quotidien les usagers
entre paris-montparanas Montel jolie
Dreux et rambouiller le directeur de la
ligne avait rencontré en décembre
dernier cinq maires du département au
cours de cette discussion les maires de
plaisir Villepreux ou encore les clés
sous-bois ont fait part de leur
mécontentement et de leur préoccupation
face au à désagrément que subissent
leurs habitants si le directeur de la
ligne a reconnu les difficultés dues à
une restitution des travaux tardifs et
un manque de personnel d'après les
informations recueillies par nos
confrères du Parisien aucun retour à la
normale n'est prévu pour les prochains
mois s'ajoute assez à dysfonctionnement
l'inquiétude de l'approche des Joos dans
le département une réunion trimestrielle
devrait tout de même être mise en place
entre les élus et la direction le
directeur de la ligne ài ça y est le
campus du PSG a accueilli tous ses
occupants les jeunes joueurs des centres
de formation et préformation du Paris
sa-germain ont fait leur rentrée au
campus de poissi ce dimanche ils ont été
accueillis par le président Nasser el
rifi au total ce sont 129 jeunes qui ont
découvert le centre d'entraînement avec
cette arrivée toutes les équipes du PSG
sont désormais réunies sur le site si
l'équipe professionnelle masculine était
déjà installée depuis juillet elle a été
rejointe par l'équipe féminine qui a
pris ses quartiers la semaine dernière
et justement ça à poissi que l'équipe
féminine disputera dorénavant ses match
oui et rendez-vous dès mercredi pour le
tout premier match dans cette nouvelle
infrastructure les parisiennes recevront
le losk à 21h pour la 12e journée de D1
si vous souhaitez y assister des places
sont encore disponibles sur la
billetterie du pariss-germain match bien
sûr à domicile on termine avec ce
rendez-vous le lancement du CES
comprenait consumer electronicque Show
de Las Vegas et des ivelinois vont
représenter le département oui le
Consumer Electronic Show pour ceux qui
ne se sont qui ne sont pas familiers
c'est le plus grand salon mondial de la
technologie il se tient aux États-Unis
du 9 au 12 janvier à 2024 et cette année
une association ivelinoise représentera
le département il s'agit de
l'association start ZUP située à
mantajolie depuis 2023 l'association
propose des formations au numérique au
public habitant dans les quartiers
prioritaires de son côté la région aussi
se mobilise Hutman nasrou vice-président
de la Région Île-de-France se rendra au
CES accompagné d'une délégation de 16
start-up franilien également élu de
Saint-Quentin en Eveline merci Michel et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi près de
chez vous vous êtes témoins d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
ielin n'hésitez pas à la partager sur
les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news